a cuatro períodos consecutivos de angela
merkel es el fin de su era que vacía o
dejara en la política y cuál es su
principal legado
bueno yo diría su principal legado es
que el proceso político las
instituciones políticas de alemania
siguen más o menos sin grandes cambios
siguen como antes no han vivido
disrupciones de populismo como estados
unidos o el reino unido eso es un gran
legado pero uno podría decir también que
ahora se suman las necesidades de cambio
se suma la necesidad de invertir en
infraestructuras
se suman las necesidades de tomar pasos
contra el cambio climático en la unión
europea existen problemas con hungría
con bolonia con deuda de autoritarismo
que se ha visto en diferentes problemas
también dentro de alemania ya una gran
grandes disputas sobre el camino hacia
el futuro que el país debe tomar
a lo que es falta un poquito ni a que
dejan muchos alemanes sin entusiasmo
para para esta temporada de elecciones
es que no debaten los cambios necesarios
lo que se debate hasta ahora son
diferentes errores que hicieron los
candidatos
de las personalidades pero en realidad
nadie ha presentado un programa
contundente y así es si profesores le
pregunto pues además de todo lo que nos
ha dicho que nadie ha presentado un
programa contundente para estas
elecciones y un plan de gobierno serio
digamos quien podría ser el nuevo de la
nueva canciller y cuál será su principal
reto entonces
en realidad hay tres candidatos del cdu
de merkel armin la chet el gobernador
del monte renania westfalia el mayor
estado de alemania aunque quien lideraba
en las encuestas pero han sido un
candidato o energético poco carismático
o indio diferentes errores como por
ejemplo reír durante un acto solemne
para las víctimas del catástrofe de
inundaciones y en el momento está detrás
del cual el candidato de los
socialdemócratas el ministro de hacienda
quien está involucrado en estos momentos
posiblemente en un escándalo de evasión
de impuestos por un banco de su estado
de hamburgo donde era gobernador y es
posible que eso le va a costar duro y en
el tercer lugar están alentada por la
candidata de los verdes quien también
estaba liderando en algún momento pero
perdió mucho debido
y también poca energía y la poca
experiencia y también un aparato
partidario un poco experimentado
profesor rápidamente ya para finalizar
garantizará la continuidad del legado de
merkel si queda en el poder la unión
democratacristiana y qué pasará entonces
si queda la posición
eso se disfruta en realidad todos tres
candidatos quieren presentarse como los
que continuarían mejor el legado de
merkel no todo el mundo quiere ser
merkel básicamente quien sigue como la
política más popular en alemania y en
realidad no creo que habrá grandes
cambios
lo que parece que habrá una coalición de
tres partidos que va a inmovilizar un
poco la política al tema así que es muy
posible que el próximo gobierno será aún
bastante inflexible bastante habrá mucha
continuidad pero también es muy posible
que va a ser algo transitorio hacia un
nuevo estilo en la política